i ragazzi e benvenuti nuovo episodio di
aprile siamo al 179 ma anche un episodio
per i 180 che sarà ovviamente pensa tra
tutti quelli speciali che ogni tanto
faccio oggi normale vediamo che che ci
cacciano fuori effettivamente quindi non
ho pretese né nulla speriamo di non
incontrare cagate però quello sempre da
180 episodi mi va bene non ho capito
sono ancora vivo perfetto non ho capito
niente di quello che è successo però
avere un orgoglio se devo prendere il
machete in partenza o che cosa del
giorno non ho capito questa truffa o
lanciato non lo schalke al traguardo
aveva un fenomeno non ho veramente
capito che cosa cosa devo fare
non ho capito slingbacks ha scritto nel
titolo anno avevo visto spacebar ea lei
allora non funziona se tengono spacebar
non funziona la battaglia di rotterdam
durante la seconda guerra mondiale hanno
rifatto hanno spiegato la storia
attraverso happy wings 2020 va bene puoi
vedere la battaglia di rotterdam la
combattuta la noce anche sicuro che la
madonna ma veramente ragazzi allora
ragazzi libro di storia non solo un
carro happy wheels ma di cosa parliamo
non serve a niente il libro di storia
qua qua la spiega una storia dai e la
battaglia la battaglia di magenta due
piedi con due mani anzi con una sola
perché non ce l'ho questa è la battaglia
alla battaglia di magenta co demonio
questi che sparano non ho capito niente
come sta succedendo ma fa niente tanto
la guerra la vinco io
e così ragazzi si svolse la battaglia di
rotterdam il prossimo episodio faremo lo
sbarco in normandia romano fa vigili
spiega la storia attraverso la bri rock
swing ko a è un rock swing fatto per il
san valentino che però è passato da un
mese
ok buon san valentino 2020 il ritardo di
un mese a tutti
avrei dovuto farla durante il san
valentino questo però chi l'aveva vi è
molto ambigua che sta questa roba che
ruote o sono io che sono pervertito in
testa ok però io non è sbagliato
insegnare la storia conetti secondo me
io in primis e lo saprei meglio se la
famiglia o ficcare dentro molto beni
perfetto sempre difficile capire le
gambe non ti servono i rock swing sei
tranquillo orco demonio proprio lui
ma no speed bike in un evo quale credo
debba andare in bici non con il pogo
però mi hai messo la scelta dei
personaggi quindi usiamo il pogo e fani
madonna che pato non sa che tesi stato
dato a posto magari metto la bici che
dire ok cos'è sta roba io lo sto capendo
niente di suoi bisogno di è più niente
neanche la roba di storica il primo
aveva fatto 5 ma data io ho fatto cinque
90 quindi lo facciamo
cambiamo il primo hai voglia di cambiar
lo faccio io reverse dato tutti sti
livelli adesso dc mezzo sono stati fatti
14 febbraio a san valentino c'è la gente
a san valentino insieme in coppia cosa
hanno fatto hanno fatto i livelli di è
meraviglioso year in the box le slot da
un po che non facevo un pd debole dovrei
fargli un pochettino più spesso perché
sono carini so che mi snervano la vita
che mi portano i nervi all'esasperazione
attenzione proprio lui che fenomeno
mamma mia mente ha piano piano a bravo
non solo è riuscito a fare un ghetti the
box decentemente ci sono dei problemi
dei problemi a ficcarmi nella scatola e
capace che per dieci minuti non ne
faccio neanche uno ragazzi
juan di terra di plater a dio santo duo
return of destiny mi sfugge cosa vuol
dire tour in italiano adesso cerco non
vorrei cercarlo ma lo cerco lo stesso a
avevo qualche dubbio finalmente non ne
ho più l'escremento del destino kamoun è
bello che anche molliccio che vivo va
bene e va ok la vera macchina da guerra
degli stati uniti è questa altro che il
detenuto che si è beccato donald trump
attenzione buonissimo proprio lui che
che si è messa a fare il suo livello che
problemi hai al cervello fatti curare ti
prego vai col o una faycal decente che
dalla vita non lo faccio trash
questo è veramente corto teoricamente se
mi lancio bene al secondo tentativo
dovrei riuscire al terzo tentativo
dovrei riuscire al quarto tentativo
dovrei riuscire a farmi fermi
eccolo
facevo cagare a scuola ma nella mia vita
qualcosa ho saputo farlo deve essere spy
formica all'indietro anno dall'alto
madonna e casinò veramente uno schifo
dall'altro non ho mai visto poteva
portare mio figlio ma figurati secolo si
fa fear e piano piano
eccolo eccolo ma non sia ok e mettilo un
traguardo che ne so io il raffanello 99
per cento impossible attenzione il
datore leggo salute rafa giocatore
impiega prega tito mappa 99 per cento
impossibili a speri tip la fanum a
cannes degli arti non ho capito niente
harmen ok non avevo capito solo sud
puglia in rumeno e mi dispiace ragazzi
mi spiace mi spiace non sapevo non
sapeva né non so anche dragostea din tei
e progetto che faceva tipo non la farò
non metterò a repentaglio la mia
eterosessualità in questo vino
attenzione però è veramente difficile
fanno un livello rumer porco del demonio
parco parco non c'è verso questo
sembravano mi sembrava più tipo
brasiliano pensi una proprio lui è
difficilissimo fa l'unica loro diritto
porca vacca hanno fatto cadere ei 6
[Musica]
no ragazzi prego ho usato una freccia
come propulsione è stata geniale sta
cosa
peccato che non ho vinto vediamo
[Musica]
cioè ho fatto una roba che non riuscirà
mai fine alla vita nella storia
l'esistenza è veramente un casino sto
vivendo porco del demonio ma li hanno
testati prima di farli attenzione
pretese uno vivo aia eccolo eccolo
proprio lui pregati the paul troisi easy
perfetto bello bello
meraviglia stavo per evitare la morte in
un modo veramente incredibile se riesco
a mettere la palla
volevo fare il figo non sono riuscito se
riesco a mettere la palla di sopra
mentre vado sulla morte teoricamente la
scampo eccolo ce l'ho fatta
ce l'ho fatta a ho lanciato pure la
morte sono fortissimo bellissimo e
suscita fare esattamente quello che
volevo fare per una volta nella vita
imposti 99 per cento madonna che fine ha
fatto mio figlio
salve a devo fermarmi e quello
l'obiettivo vista e non o non ho
lavorato per fare questa cosa attenzione
devo andare piano figlio frenati questa
volta teoricamente dovrei riuscire orco
demonio visto come riesco bene
madonna avranno inculcati come puoi
fermarti prima non puoi mano poi non
tipo ma non puoi fermarti impossibile
ragazzi orale ma neanche rallentano
cielo porco del demonio
tutto a posto ragazzi
e vabbè ma imposto una visura buono
buono ma loro no
proprio lui mario car mario kart è bello
bellissimo sa veramente di mario kart
sto livello complimenti c'è la macchina
si manca un po tutto il resto però a
salve
mio dio ho massacrato with you anzi loro
hanno massacrato me molto meglio
in tutto questo sta andando avanti la
macchina non si sa come credo di aver
perso un timpano pro fa niente ciao
fabio sono sempre io per ragazzini
stavano spero che tu possa fare questo
livello e vincerlo fidati e possibile di
consiglio di usare quello con il pogo
ciao ne sarebbe per forza consigliare
l'hai messo l'hai messo standard
indicati
ok ok proprio lui non sono riuscito per
niente bello però è bravo sei stato
bravo c'è anche un green screen
così giampiero può mettere i gattini
sfondo grande giampiero sì proprio lui
conosce anche giampiero sto ragazzino di
savona attenzione chi è re indiscusso io
quanto [ __ ] ciò nessuno signori spero
che vi sia piaciuto questo ap wales 179
il prossimo sarà un po uno special
perché facciamo ogni 10 bisogni ogni 5
10 quando mi girano le palle faccio uno
special di dei top livelli ciliano forse
l'episodio iscritte che lei sia cioè
della campanellina prima della giornata
i film in sé non è come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo film ei ragazzi
[Musica]